monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
en décidant dans la nuit du 23 au 24
février
de déclencher une attaque militaire
massive contre l'ukraine
la fédération de russie a commis un acte
de guerre qui enfreint toutes les règles
du droit international
rompt avec tous ses engagements et
surtout bafoue les valeurs de paix et de
liberté
sur lesquels le continent européen a
construit son équilibre depuis plusieurs
décennies
comme le président de la république l'a
souligné nous faisons face à une
situation de guerre mais également un
tournant dans l'histoire de l'europe et
de notre pays
je veux le redire ici d'emblée la france
condamne de la manière la plus absolue
cette agression cynique et préméditée
en ces instants tragiques
je veux redire tout notre soutien au
peuple ukrainien
qui vit des moments terribles
ainsi qu'à toutes les victimes de ce
drame absolument inconcevable
entre deux pays voisins
en europe au 21ème siècle
je veux également dire
mon admiration
au président tel un ski qui
au président c'est lens qui qui depuis
kiev a siégé mène le combat et fait face
avec courage
responsabilités et d'initier je veux
enfin salué le travail remarquable de
nos agents de l'ambassade de france à nu
crenn et plus largement celui des agents
de l'état qui jour et nuit ce relais
pour porter assistance aux français et
marquer notre soutien aux autorités
ukrainiennes
cette équipe cette équipe peut sous
l'autorité de notre ambassadeur etienne
de poncins
oeuvre dans des conditions
particulièrement difficiles
pour des raisons de sécurité de nos
agents elle s'est déplacée hier de kiev
et lviv nous restons extrêmement
attentifs à sa protection
la gravité de la situation
m'a conduit à proposer
dès la semaine dernière au président de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat aux
présidents de groupe et des commissions
compétentes des deux assemblées
de réunir 100 élèves un comité de
liaison qui nous a permis de partager
vendredi dernier des informations
importantes et de répondre à l'essentiel
des questions
qu'ils ont bien voulu nous soumettre
j'ai invité hier dans le même esprit les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
j'ai souhaité également est évidemment
répondre à la demande légitime que la
représentation nationale tout entière
puisse s'exprimer sur ce sujet de la
plus haute importance
ce qui me conduit à vous soumettre
aujourd'hui une déclaration au titre de
l'article
50-1 de la constitution portant sur le
conflit en ukraine cette déclaration
sera suivie d'un débat
mesdames et messieurs les députés
la france n'a pas ménagé ses efforts ces
dernières semaines et ces derniers mois
pour faire valoir jusqu'au bout la voix
de la raison et de la paix tel est
d'ailleurs la ligne constante qu a suivi
notre diplomatie
vis-à-vis de la russie du président
poutine depuis le président chirac
ce fut le cas dans le cadre du conflit
en géorgie avec le président nicolas
sarkozy
ce fut le cas encore pour l'ukraine
depuis le premier jour des tensions en
2013 et dans la suite des accords de
minsk de 2014 signé alors que le
président hollande était à l'elysée en
tant que membre permanent du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies en tant que
présidente un exercice du conseil de
l'union européenne
au regard aussi de ce que sont ces
valeurs et l'idée qu'elle se fait de la
paix et du mode de résolution des
conflits la france se devait d'affût
mais son rôle les initiatives prises par
le chef de l'état se sont multipliés en
liaison étroite avec nos partenaires
européens
et les états unis
ces efforts n'ont pas abouti
vladimir poutine a non seulement
déchirés les accords de minsk mais il a
aussi rompu tous ses engagements qu'il
avait pris dans les derniers jours il
emporte la pleine et entière
responsabilité
évidemment la france n'a jamais
sous-estimer le risque du scénario du
pire
nous observions avec nos partenaires et
alliés le déploiement progressif
d'un dispositif militaire massif en
biélorussie aux frontières de l'ukraine
en mer noire
plus de cent cinquante mille hommes
équipés des moyens les plus modernes
un dispositif militaire dans vadimir
poutine assurait qu'il se retirerait une
fois les exercices terminés
tout en appelant au dialogue
diplomatique sur des garanties de
sécurité pour la russie tout en répétant
que la russie ne s'apprêtaient pas à
acquérir l'ukraine
vladimir poutine a menti
il a menti au président de la république
il a menti à la communauté
internationale il a menti à son propre
peuple non aucun génocide n'a eu lieu
contre les populations russophones du
dombass non il n'ya pas d'armes
nucléaires sur le sol ukrainien
non monsieur et d'un ce qui n'est pas à
la tête d'un régime nazi thème
particulièrement infâme quand il est
appliqué un pays pleinement démocratique
la suite vous la connaissez
le 21 février les masques sont tombés
la reconnaissance par le président de la
fédération de russie des deux régions
séparatistes de l'est de l'ukraine
l'ordre donné aux forces russes
d'occuper ces territoires et l'invasion
de l'ensemble du territoire ukrainien
depuis la russie la crimée et la
biélorussie constitue le premier acte de
cette crise qui sera sans doute longue
vladimir poutine a fait le choix de la
guerre il a fait le choix de vouloir
inverser le cours de l'histoire
et de revenir sur les acquis qui avait
suivi la fin de l'union soviétique
il a pris le prétexte de la situation
dans la région du don de base pour
violer la souveraineté territoriale
et cherché à renverser le gouvernement
légitime
d'un pays de 44 millions d'habitants
face à cette agression inacceptable
il convient de réagir dans l'unité et
dans la durée pour à la fois soutenir
nos amis ukrainiens et ne pas laisser
cet acte de guerre sans réponse ni
conséquence
nous devons pour cela mesdames et
messieurs les députés nous appuyer sur
quatre principes d'action
le premier principe c'est la fermeté
d'abord dans l'enceinte des nations
unies la résolution présenté en urgence
devant le conseil de sécurité n'a pas
été adopté en raison du droit de veto
russe mais elle a permis de démontrer
l'isolément de la russie de même
que les échanges en assemblée générale
qui ont suivi et donné lieu à une
condamnation ferme par la communauté
internationale
ensuite par la mise en place de
plusieurs trains de sanctions que nous
avons voulu prendre très rapidement
le conseil européen sous présidence
française
a ainsi approuvé trois paquets de
sanctions les 23 25 et 27 février
ces mesures prises en coordination avec
nos alliés couvre un éventail large des
activités économiques russes tout
d'abord nous avons décidé d'un sécher la
capacité de financement extérieur de
l'économie russe depuis hier 4 heures du
matin toutes les transactions avec les
réserves de la banque centrale russe
sont interdites et les avoirs de la
banque centrale russe détenue à
l'étranger sont gelés
cette mesure est complété par
l'interdiction imposée à la majorité des
banques russes d'accéder à la messagerie
de transmission des paiements swift ce
paquet de sanctions financières est
inédit par son ampleur
et ses effets sont déjà palpables le
rouble a dévissé de près de 30% à
l'ouverture des marchés lundi matin
l'union européenne a également fermé
l'intégralité de son espace aérien aux
aéronefs et aux compagnies aériennes
russes y compris l'aviation d'affaires
en outre
les avoirs et les ressources économiques
détenues et contrôlées
par les personnes sur lesquelles
s'appuie le pouvoir de vladimir poutine
ont été gelés toutes les personnes
visées très précisément
476 à ce jour à ce jour ne pourront plus
accéder à les avoir à leurs avoirs
détenus dans les pays y compris
vous l'aurez bien notés la suisse
qui ont pris ces sanctions et ne
pourront plus s'y rendre
lundi mire poutine fait d'ailleurs
partie de la liste des personnes sous
sanctions tout comme sergueï lavrov par
ailleurs les différentes coopérations
entre l'union européenne et la russie
dans les domaines industriels
scientifiques ou culturelles sont
suspendus le conseil européen a
également demandé la préparation d'un
paquet de sanctions ce sera le quatrième
contre la biélorussie
et les échanges mesdames et messieurs
les députés se poursuivent pour aller
plus loin nous y sommes prêts
l'essentiel était d'agir rapidement
de bien cibler nos mesures pour qu'elle
produise un effet massif sur l'économie
russe à court terme bien sûr mais aussi
et surtout dans la durée quitte à les
durcir encore par étapes au cours des
prochains jours
évidemment ces sanctions ne seront pas
indolore pour nos économies européennes
nous le savons et nous devons l'assumer
sauf à se contenter de mesures sans
réelle portée bien sûr nous savons que
la russie arrêtera à son tour des contre
mesures
mais nous y sommes prêts
et nous allons accompagner
nos concitoyens et nos entreprises afin
d'encaisser au mieux les impacts
économiques de ces mesures notamment les
probables tensions sur les
approvisionnements
et sur les prix de certains produits
à la demande du président de la
république le gouvernement prépare à cet
effet un plan de résilience qui sera
finalisée dans les tout prochains jours
je pense en particulier
à certaines de nos filières
industrielles et agricoles
je pense aussi aux ménages en tant que
consommateur d'énergie d'autant qu'ils
sont déjà très impactée depuis plusieurs
mois par un mouvement de hausse très
puissant pour tous ces acteurs de notre
vie économique et sociale
des mesures très fortes de protection
ont déjà été prises depuis septembre
dernier et vous avez eu à débattre de la
plupart d'entre elles le bouclier est
tarifaires sur les prix de l'énergie a
ainsi permis de consacrer plus de 16
milliards d'euros à la protection de nos
concitoyens et de nos entreprises face à
la hausse que nous anticipions des prix
de l'énergie
ces mesures
d'accompagnement et de protection seront
prolongées et renforcer autant que
nécessaire sur la base des travaux en
cours
mais c'est bien la russie qui va
souffrir le plus des conséquences de ces
sanctions
la guerre unilatérale et injustifié que
vladimir poutine a déclenché aura un
coût indéniable pour lui et ses soutiens
la fermeté
le deuxième principe de notre action
c'est la solidarité avec le peuple et le
gouvernement ukrainien
cette solidarité le président de la
république a réitéré au président et
l'ins qui lors de leur entretien quasi
quotidiens cette solidarité nous
l'exprimons symboliquement par le
maintien de notre représentation
diplomatique
et par l'attention permanente que nous
portons à nos ressortissants
à ce jour ce sont environ un millier de
nos compatriotes qui sont encore à nuque
rennes nous sommes en contact avec eux
dans le cadre du dispositif mis en place
sous l'autorité du ministre de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères d équipe
consulaire ont été déployés au poste
frontière dans les pays limitrophes pour
accueillir nos concitoyens qu'ils
veulent et peuvent quitter le pays hier
vous le savez la possibilité de quitter
kiev par le sud leur a ainsi été
signalés
nous exprimons aussi notre soutien par
un appui économique renforcée portant
sur 30 300 millions d'euros d'aidé
immédiate
nous soutenons également
les forces armées ukrainiennes
avec des livraisons de carburant et de
matériel militaire y compris
d'armement en lien avec nos partenaires
européens nous continuerons de le faire
aussi longtemps que nécessaire
nous nous préparons au niveau de l'union
européenne à faire face aux conséquences
humanitaires de cette crise je pense
évidemment en particulier à l'afflux de
réfugiés
dont on peut craindre qu'il soit massif
le mécanisme de protection civile de
l'union européenne a été activée dans ce
cadre
33 tonnes de matériel humanitaire
partis de paris sont déjà arrivés à la
frontière ukrainienne les acheminements
se poursuivront cette semaine incluant
de l'aide médicale
la france soutiendra aussi les pays
frontalier de l'ukraine qui
accueilleront les réfugiés et nous
proposerons dans le cadre de la
présidence de l'union qu'un dispositif
de solidarité
permette une juste répartition des
efforts
d'accueil de ces réfugiés entre les pays
de l'union je veux à ce stade aussi pour
ma réjouir souligné la forte
mobilisation spontanée de nos
concitoyens des collectivités
territoriales
du milieu du milieu associatif
pour apporter une aide humanitaire au
peuple ukrainien cet honneur de
générosité cet élan de générosité fait
honneur à la france et l'état bien
entendu l'accompagnera
troisième principe de notre action
l'unité tout ce que nous faisons nous le
décidons conjointement avec nos
partenaires au sein de l'union
atlantique et de l'union européenne
vous l'avez vu et constaté mesdames et
messieurs les députés la réponse de
l'europe a été rapide
la réponse de l'europe a été forte
et nous entendons
amplifier encore cette réponse
cette unité cette rapidité
cette intensité
ont surpris y compris sans doute le
président poutine cette unité cette
rapidité
cette intensité sont inédits nous
pouvons être fiers de l'europe
nous pouvons
un peu fier
nous pouvons être fiers du rôle que la
présidence française a pu jouer pour la
stimuler car la france le président de
la république et le gouvernement sont à
la manoeuvre est à l'initiative
tout cela nous montre le cap faire des
européens des acteurs de leur sécurité
collective et renforcer leur
souveraineté
cet enjeu que je vous le rappelle la
france porte depuis notamment le
discours prononcé par le président de la
république à la sorbonne saura au coeur
du prochain conseil européen des 10 et
11 mars prochains
le quatrième principe enfin
et sans doute le plus difficile en ce
moment
c'est le maintien du dialogue
comme je voulais déjà dit la diplomatie
française n'a pas ménagé ses efforts
pour éviter cette crise et chercher le
chemin de la désescalade le présent de
la république s'est personnellement
engagé et continue elle a simplement à
le faire nous restons persuadés en effet
que la diplomatie a encore toute sa
place pour mettre fin à la guerre et
nous continuerons de dialoguer avec tous
les protagonistes de cette crise sans
relâcher nos efforts et bien entendu
sans céder sur les principes du droit et
du respect de la souveraineté des états
car le dialogue est indispensable
mais si vladimir poutine ou ses
collaborateurs
souhaitent négocier
ils le doivent d'abord faire taire les
armes
encore hier le chef de l'état s'est
entretenu longuement avec le président
russe il a réitéré auprès de nuit la
demande de la communauté internationale
d'un cessez le feu hi media il a appelé
au respect du droit international
humanitaire et de la protection
des populations civiles comme de
l'acheminement de l'aide
conformément à la résolution portée par
la france au conseil de sécurité des
nations unies
mesdames et messieurs les députés
cette crise sera longue et aura des
conséquences majeures sur l'avenir de
l'europe
mais pour autant c'est bien le droit la
paix et la démocratie
qui devront à la fin en sortir vainqueur
nous venons d'assister
ou nous sommes en train d'assister un
premier acte
un premier acte qui n'est pas terminée
et qui fait apparaître à la fois le
déséquilibre des forces en présence mais
aussi le courage admirable
du peuple ukrainien
monsieur l'ambassadeur
et la mobilisation de la communauté
internationale
nous avons toujours été clairs et nos
amis ukrainiens l'ont d'emblée compris
un pays comme la france ne peut recourir
à la force que si elle est directement
attaqués ou dans le cadre des systèmes
d' allianz dont elle fait partie
l'alliance atlantique dont nous sommes
membres est une alliance défensive
elle se défend lorsque l'un de ses
membres est agressée et l'ukraine vous
le savez n'est pas membre de l'otan il
n'y a donc aucun doute que nous serions
amenés à nous engager militairement dans
la protection de nos alliés de l'est de
l'europe si le conflit devait connaître
d'autres extensions au delà du
territoire ukrainien dans les pays
membres de l'alliance le président de la
république a d'ores et déjà décidé de
renforcer notre participation au
dispositif de l'otan dans les pays
baltes en pologne et en roumanie
tout en restant engagé dans
l'approfondissement de l'europe de la
défense
la france tient sa place de membre actif
solidaire est impliqué dans l'alliance
atlantique à ce titre je rappelle à la
représentation nationale que nos forces
armées participent sans interruption
depuis 2010 est à la réassurance de nos
alliés orientaux notamment dans les pays
baltes où notre engagement va se
poursuivre à terre et dans les airs nous
allons également prendre la tête en tant
que nation cadre d'un bataillon
multinational
qui va se déployer cette semaine en
roumanie
nous mettant donc à neuf recoller ctive
mans
tous les moyens possibles pour écrire
les actes suivants de cette crise elle
va s'inscrire dans le temps long
le peuple russe va être lui aussi
la victime collatérale des décisions de
vladimir poutine
peut-être n'at-il pas encore conscience
un brevet par une propagande médiatique
qui travestit la réalité des faits
je ne suis pas certain que ce soit le
destin qu'ils aient choisi car le peuple
russe est un grand peuple
les efforts de guerre qu'il faudra payer
les sanctions économiques subies la mise
au ban des nations
va appauvrir et affaiblir la russie au
détriment de son peuple qui n'a
évidemment pas été consulté avant la
décision prise par son président nous
devons donc nous adresser au grand
peuple russe est clairement mené la
bataille de la communication
là encore dans un cadre partenarial
comme nous avons commencé à le faire
avec les chaînes d'information ou plutôt
de désinformation contrôlée par le
pouvoir russe
mesdames et messieurs les députés
vous l'aurez compris
l'agression de l'ukraine par les forces
de vladimir poutine va bien au delà d'un
simple conflit entre deux pays
celtes agression qu'il qualifie dans son
art hâtif d'opérations militaires est
une atteinte aux principes les plus
fondamentaux
du droit international de souveraineté
et d'intégrité des états
ces bruits de bottes à l'est de l'europe
nous replonge dans des périodes de
l'histoire que nous pensions durablement
derrière nous
à cela nous voulons répondre
différemment et collectivement en
privilégiant la plus grande fermeté dans
nos actions
l'unité entre alliés et partenaires
européens et surtout la solidarité
avec le peuple ukrainien et ses
dirigeants qui par leur résistance leur
dignité leur courage force notre
admiration et nous oblige nous devons
être à leurs côtés pour les soutenir
aujourd'hui et demain par tous les
moyens utiles à la fin des fins nous
devrons toujours cherché à privilégier
larmes de la diplomatie la seule qui
vaille dans nos démocraties
nous le ferons nous adressons au peuple
russe et ukrainien qui compose de peuple
mature et à qui nous rappelleront
incessamment que la voie de la force et
de l'impérialisme finit toujours par
conduire à l'impasse si aujourd'hui les
chars russes envahissent qui est et non
pas budapest ou bragg c'est justement
parce que l'europe a su construire avec
ses partenaires autour d' aspiration
commune un ensemble sur unie prospère
le peuple ukrainien
aspire dans sa majorité à rejoindre cet
ensemble à s'associer à ce mouvement
ce mouvement reprendra car c'est le sens
de l'histoire je vous remercie
merci mme thomas rasset